Wordsmith hello we've got important work
to get to so I won't keep you the word
we're looking at in this video is
significant
signifant it's an adjective it means
important worth paying attention to a
large amount something can be
emotionally significant right
emotionally important or there can be a
significant scientific development a
development worth paying attention to or
maybe someone has just given you a
significant amount which is to say a lot
of old vinyl records which you have no
way of playing this word comes to French
by way of Latin so its derivation is a
little complicated sign means what it
means in English it's the same deal as
the English word sign it's a marker it's
a thing with meaning thick comes from a
Latin verb meaning to make an ant comes
from French and it makes words into
adjectives and sometimes nouns so we
have significant now right and when we
put all of those word Parts together to
form significant we get a word that
describes something that is is making
meaning you can think of it as being
something so important or so large that
it would Merit its own sign like like
the the world's largest rubber band ball
having its own billboard along the
highway that's significant for a given
value of significance so what can you
think of that uses some of these word
Parts sign thick or ant what words can
you assemble using those word parts
let's throw 10 seconds on the clock and
I'll put on some music here we
[Music]
go here are three words I came up with
signature your name in handwriting it
comes from the Latin for a thing that
has been marked with a stamp or a sign
like an official
document signify is a verb that means to
make meaning to make clear or evident
this eight-sided red sign that says stop
signifies that it's time to stop
insignificant which is merely the
opposite of significant I've just taken
the prefix in which here means not and
popped it onto the front this is in my
opinion a super villain word you
insignificant worm that it feels like a
villainous thing to to call someone you
got to sneer when you say it
insignificant if you were worms
wordsmiths I do not think you would be
insignificant worms I think you are very
important worms so follow me Wiggly
Friends oh over to the sentence sandbox
where I'm going to use significant in
some examples the giant Squid's suckers
did significant damage to the hull of
the Good Ship undertoe so I'm using
significant here to mean a lot the squid
really messed up the Good Ship undertoe
those poor Sailors they've been through
so much now let me use significant to
mean important or noteworthy the most
significant change Alisa made to her
bike is definitely the wings right that
change is the most notable most
motorcycles don't have magnificent wings
of
Steel it is their presence and indeed
their magnificence that is notable
wordsmiths you too can soar on wings of
Steel if you hold fast to one truth you
can learn anything David out